every once in a while and get your
vision checked and as a chess player you
should test your chess vision maybe once
a week and this is going to be the start
of a new series you can find in my
personal youtube channel youtube.com
slash Daniel wrench where we test our
chess visualization skills so I'm gonna
start out do three each time we're gonna
start out with just the coordinates and
push ourselves to raise the limit of how
quickly how accurately we can coordinate
and see the board improving our
calculation skills then we're gonna
practice moves and then we're gonna have
a mix of both the hardest is to have a
mix of both and have it switch from both
white and blacks perspective here we go
I'm gonna start out for the first time
ever putting my money on the line I have
the record right now amongst the chest
comm staff here we go with vision
training h 5 h 5 f 2 f 4 e 3 wow I'm
getting all dark squares here there we
go a 5 f8 g 3 e 6 d3 g 1 g 4 of 6 h 5 g
8 c 6 before a 2 F 1 C 7 e 4 h 1 g 4 a 7
e 8 don't start dragging on me Mouse ah
that's actually my new record that was
30 of 30 and I was I was moving to C 1
to click it ok
I'm pretty proud of myself that's a new
record and I can prove it to our staff
Mamie J our co-founder who says well no
one can see exactly how good you are at
this visualization stuff Danny I'm like
hey I'm pushing the limit here I already
claimed 26 and now we know I have 30
it's on record take that J yeah the
challenge is on record yourself doing
the vision we'll see that now let's move
on to the harder one harder one here we
go we're gonna move two moves away from
coordinates I think my record here is 23
ready set go
rookie for King of 725 F 392 King III
Knight c3 Bishop c5
488 g7 community 394 we should be one oh
I almost messed that one up Queen before
mercy for her I feel like I'm going slow
right now ah I tied my record I don't
think I've ever gotten past 23 and I was
I was I was clicking on the pawn all
right well that's fun now we move on to
the real test where you're you're
balancing back and forth you can't sit
on the type of one that our vision
trainer is asking of you
we got pieces and they got movements and
squares ready set Freddie
f5 Bishop u 1 d 8 d 4 C 7 would be one
go fast come on come on go fast ah f 1 c
3 d 7 d 7 C 6 D 3 oh I broke my record I
did better on that than I did on the on
the single piece movement I was I was
moving the King to g4 - alright well now
we've set the tone 30 squares only 23 on
record for peace movements 28 with mixed
doubles as I call it now flipping the
board is an important challenge because
one of the biggest issues people have
when visualizing is mixing up the
squares obviously here there are no
coordinates that's the whole point of
our vision trainers you're training
yourself to understand that I'll give
you the quick chess lecture b4 and g5
for the same square you know B 5 and G
for the same square G 8 and B 1 of the
same square the board is an 8 by 8 you
know rotating color grid and when you're
look at it from the black side and
you're calculating keeping track of
pieces in your head sometimes people can
confuse the coordinates or actually
struggle with what the squares are at a
basic level and actually get better this
is never an issue anymore but what is an
issue and one of the things people
underestimate about about vision
training is that often the reason you're
making blunders in your games has
nothing to do with a lack of positional
understanding or I go there he goes
there I go there he goes there type of
calculation it has to do with your
ability to keep things organized in the
variation itself so I'll put it this way
it's not the lack of being able to
imagine the pieces moving in your head
it's the ability to keep track of where
the pieces are at the end of a line so
you've calculated 5 6 moves and you
forgot you know that a knight took a
pawn on a diagonal and then it moved in
the next part of the variation and
unleashed a bishop on g7 to your rook on
a 1 then what often happens in the game
is you start executing this combination
you realize halfway through that it
doesn't work and you blunder you know
it's a basic example but often if you're
making blunders tactically it's because
of lack of full board awareness and lack
of vision training more than it even is
about tactical patterns and of course at
a basic level that you know I can be
overstepping a little bit you have to
know your tactical patterns you have to
recognize what type of common themes
occur all the time again staff you can
structure and isolated pawn so you push
yourself to add little pieces of
knowledge in your head but the vision
trainer helps you to kind of put that
together and pushes you to to know the
board as well as as you can and ends it
as things change you can keep them keep
them organized in your head now we plan
on improving this tool we're gonna do a
lot more I have a lot of ideas that that
have not been executed yet because
they're a little bit more complicated
than what we've developed so far but
this is still a lot of fun so I'm gonna
put my money where my mouth is now and
do one from the black side where now I
have to remember that this square is a
eight not h1 and we'll see how I'm able
to do we know I have 38 of 30 in the in
the white side and let's see how I can
do from my this is the first time I've
ever solved from the black side actually
at least as far as our trainer goes so B
2 that means this is B 2 that means this
is C 8 that means this is if oh I'm
doing mixed I forgot I forgot I was
doing mixed F 3 it should be 3 Queens
you to Bishop f8 I it is it is that's
not e3 that's H 6 C it is it is it
definitely throws you off because I was
just doing this um she won ok came to d4
I was just doing this you know from the
other side B 6 d 3c I'd rather go slower
but get them all right until I can until
I can quickly switch the side of the
board that I'm that I'm calculating from
and and now you know solving from the
the mixed version where it's gonna
change each time it's gonna tell us
whether we're looking at from the white
or black perspective this is actually a
new feature and I think is even more
challenging for your vision and your
quick awareness of the board so I'm
looking at must be looking at it from
white side where does it tell you
now I'm looking from black sites so that
means h3 is here okay so I'm getting it
qd6 I'm looking at it from the black
side Bishop b8 I'm looking for the
blacks Queen Age 3 I'm looking at this
from the white side okay so I'm living
on the black side that means this is g2
this is actually really good this is
really challenging so I'm white Bishop
e6 from the black side c3 from the black
side a5 from the black side Bishop e8
from the ah this should be from the
white side okay so just would have been
bishop EA
Wow that's difficult and I really like
that 11 out of 11 is a much slower pace
than I'm happy with and that's a
different challenge than I've ever done
from the from the perspective of getting
one color or just being able to roll
through but take the challenge yourself
have fun using our vision trainer I'm
gonna offer tips and advice weekly moves
we do this um this fun little contest
and try to work on our vision like I
said go to get your eyes checked out so
you're not driving blind okay I mean
that's just that's just like pro tip for
life hashtag you're welcome
and get your vision checked on chess
calm everybody